hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play don't make me
turn this guy around you little [ __ ]
dude this is a game where you play as a
disgruntled parent trying to drive his
kids home and they keep bothering you on
the way which was made during the
Walking Dead game Jim so let's get to it
I've tested it out a little bit and boy
does it not suck here is awesome
the gameplays actually kind of fun I
haven't gone very far in it Matthew
pinches his brother hey settle down back
there settle down I'm trying to get you
home so just please please I'm begging
you please be nice to me I just had a
bad day at the office no don't you
settle that would high I'm slowly uh-oh
I think me and my kids just died
horribly in a fireball but I couldn't
quite tell because there was no sound
remember this was a quickly made game
and just embrace it for the heart of
what it is and what it is a game about
trying to get home where my damn bastard
kids done it ok no you always start out
with a pack oh this is gonna be
fantastic
in case you didn't know taking your eyes
off the road to look at your kids is a
bad idea and pretty no you always pinch
Simon you let Simon alone just because
he's a stupid dork and glasses back
there doesn't mean that you get to pee
Zim couldn't even think of a word no no
can a car what kind of floaty ass car is
this ok anyway might know you're hungry
wait what no hang on wait no there you
go listen kids Wow let's have to flip
the car back over damn I am strong as
hell I guess I'm super caring mom oh I'm
a woman oh okay alright just there I
know you're thirsty we don't have time
to stop for gas because oh what my
sanity what are you even talking about
oh I guess the game's over Jesus look at
your stats they're rocketing up like
nobody's business
all right let's go for you know what I
don't have time to waste on you kids
your mother is feeling pretty bad I
don't ask my voice just got this deep
because I've had Astrid no you
always start with the benching don't do
the pinching leave your door Koosh
brother alone everyone knows that kids
who wear glasses are stupid idiots yeah
I'm a hungry dyed dingus Oh what where
are we now
are we in space kids I pretty sure this
is where we go to die little bit nice
nice little kiddies and don't do nothing
that Santa Claus wouldn't want you to do
nope nope nope that'd be nice for once
in your life just wait till your dad
gets home or we get home to see your dad
you gotta get five across the ass that's
with five nice ritalin in your damn
drink so that oh god super mom got the
car back in order just be nice don't
make me turn this car around not this is
how we die hug each other and kiss your
asses goodbye I am your mother listen to
me I don't care if we're skidding all
over the road
I don't care if I Drive this car into a
pit of hell anything would save me from
my life that got cut short by getting
pregnant in high school I was gonna be
the expert figure skater back in
Guadalajara and goddamn it kids
lick on your kids to improve their mood
cuz everyone every parent knows clicking
repeatedly on your kids improves their
mood oh my god why didn't the game just
over oh where are we going oh we're
playing Rock'em Sock'em robots with this
car oh my god you're thirsty a drink
drink your bastards grace my kids with a
response this time I'm gonna focus 100%
on just getting the F home because this
cannot be good for anybody
don't do it all I'm gonna do is oh no
come on
why does the flick not work I don't care
who your father is all of you have
different fathers you know what I'm
telling you that that that's right
it's about Todd I've been I've been
having it up here you're not even my
kids I'm not even your mother do you you
had you were dropped out shut up you
were dropped off by everything to get to
nowhere and then but I don't even know
what I'm talking about anymore but you
need to shut the F up do you know what
kids we're gonna stop in this gas
station I'm gonna abandon you and I'm
gonna go on to my dreams to be a Las
Vegas stripper no Park here you're gonna
empty your bowels gonna bar drinks I'm
gonna withdraw all of my money I'm gonna
throw my fuel do a son of a [ __ ]
bastard he's crap there we go we got so
many snacks now you'll never cuz I know
what is best dr. Marvin oh oh oh eat
something
just shove food into your face we'll be
there in no time shut up stop being so
damn hungry you've been in the car for
two minutes oh and I'm gonna ignore him
that's all yet that's all yeah that's
all the treatment how I wouldn't dare
swear at you kids oh god how is how
you're all right how okay flip correct
no game over just all of a sudden oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I'm not
gonna grace you with a response
no I don't
Oh what what happened
you know what don't make me turn this
car around guess what I think the only
way to win this game is to turn the
effing car around
oh but apparently I can't reverse and it
is not doing anything I turn this car
around I did it I turned the car around
I did it you know what floatie ass
controls though ain't gonna stop me as I
turn the effing car around and I win you
know what I won cuz I did with the game
told me to do you know what I'm done
so how about this take this car you
shove it up your ass and you little
kitties burn in hell how about that you
okay goodbye
I'm sorry I yelled at you kiddies iviews
upset over the hope situation hate to
tell you this but your little dog peanut
butter I ran him over in my car as why
this car isn't running well cuz it's
dying dead corpses stuck in the left
rear tire he's so dead daddy is he's
really dead you kiddies also all your
parents are getting a divorce
I loathe I hate you